e non guardarci nuovissima escape room
dobbiamo ricavare dalla palestra
malefica così allora gli stivali bianchi
vestitino bianco effetto parlare lo devo
dire sono tutti gli stivali da portare
sempre sulla tuta aiea gli stessi o
rechi in gioco a forma di fragola come
sempre mettetevi comodi prendete i pop
corn stati eseguiti ancora senso che la
mandate seguirmi e iniziamo subito con
questo
eccoci qua è l'allenatore che dice bene
cerchiamo di mettersi in forma ma ora
questi poverini lo stesso dal brano
molto felici il falso battendo che un po
difficile con vitale se già sfracellati
vuole contare quante volte si accelera
52 permettere un contatore vedi ogni
volta che vi dc così gravi anche dove
potrebbero mettere un contatore che
conta con tre volte dice sfracellato
sarebbe divertente puoi vedere alla fine
prezzolato più tesa ma in realtà noi
abbiamo già un contatto ore perché il
nostro contatore siete voi questa volta
che come più prime tre dita si no
non ci posso credere mi sto distraendo
troppo ok ora è ancora più persone
povere non è disperata sul tapis roulant
ok devo stare molto attento non farvi
distrarre da tutti queste barrette di
cioccolato resta è il livello per vitale
cosa abbiamo barretta di cioccolato
questa potenza buone perché è questo che
cos'è nostri butterò intero quartiere
questa persona acqua che dice ho bisogno
delle caramelle ma stava cercando di
mangiare dal distributore l'abbiamo
fatto che cosa dice questo al bello
allora l'allenatore dicevo gli occhi e
muoviate quelle gambe non toccare il
pavimento oppure sei fuori una maestra
gigante a me questa ricorda la palestra
della scuola è vero ma dove sono finite
paraico sono sottili sono caduta voce
tipo il paradiso del po con una balestra
non vorrei dire che non ci credo che è
vitale mi ha preparato ma già due delle
cose che qua bisogna tenere l'equilibrio
e devo dire che cosa scrivo lungo e ci
sta facendo fare il gimnasia è bello
fare ginnastica così invece di andare a
sudare
bello no ci puoi anche riuscire a
saltare su da uno all'altro vedo destra
e montana noi non cadere ok
stavo per cadere ma io sono qui ti sto
aspettando da uno sfregio ma bisogna
evitare quegli angoli you
ecco vitale c'è la fase di certo la
faccia ormai sono bravissimi
il meeting è ovvio mi sento attento
ancora bisogna esaltare dura questi cubi
diventano sempre più difficili vedi
perché assistiamo quasi ci siamo quasi
dobbiamo evitare i stanchi da boxe
facile c'è il ring per area wrestling ei
ma quello è un ragazzo ciccione gigante
no una brutta imprendo nel secondo game
room e cioè milanello bocchino viene a
fare la bocca di qualcuno è sicuramente
vediamo
[Risate]
[Musica]
il vantaggio 2
aspettiamo vitale vediamo se sarà fatta
da youtube possiamo farcela ma allora
l'allenatore dice siamo stati mangiati
ma voglio comunque vedere quei muscoli
bruciare per conto è allenarsi anche se
siamo stati file diana che cosa si è
mangiato per intero è rivolta scopriamo
cosa si sono mangiati senza averlo
masticata e poi soprattutto dopo ci sarà
la parte perfino i dati fino al mediano
ci finiremo in un gabinetto vate cosa ha
mangiato un pezzo di pizza 3 farini ecco
qua questo è difficile questi difficile
piano piano
no non ho mai detto piano piano vediamo
questi sfugge alla vita in aiuto ma va
dai solo 1 ora saliamo nella spina
dorsale vediamo dove arriviamo
stadi vitale qualche volta
ma perché questa parte deve essere così
brutta e funzione no va beh veramente
difficile con la santa in continuazione
dai forse solo facciamo saltata da
allora una tecnica e saltare in
continuazione poi si può dargli di
niente poi ci riusciva facilmente a
farlo in questo pezzo qui ci sono quasi
si evince dai giovani nei romanzi
forse ce l'ho fatta forse sono un fatto
capire che questa fase lo dice mi
dispiace scusa per quello accusa per
aver vivere la villetta ok ora
aspettiamo vitalità e puoi farcela
vitale e comitato questo punto ne
usciamo fuori dal mio padre di tutte le
mani se qualcuno qua ci sono altre sei
finito ok siamo qui a marche come fa
quella persona tagliando bugatti tra le
caramelle le posso prendere il nome non
funziona adesso chissà che dobbiamo
votare
l'allenatore dice non ci sono scuse
inizia a notare che non è la piscina
vergogna sono è andare l'acqua hanno le
docce queste bestie dopo che abbiamo
studiato così tanto in palestra eco vita
ho scritto non imbrogliare fai il tuo
round nella piscina di paolo ciò ben
salvagente sì va bene lo chiamo già
bella dai quest anno fa è bello non so
perchè ma mi viene voglia di buttarvi
nella con successo se mi butto orge di
averlo fatto splash
ok arrivo anche se vorrei entrare nella
vicina a nuotare perché toni tedofora un
po di caldo ecco qua le altre john bell
e salviamo le ore dove finiremo che
chiedono grado sono chiusi ma puoi
camminare sui capitali da uno store
risalendo nello scivolo come steri soldi
voglio rifare lo scivolo perché mi ha
fatto cadere fuori via buttiamoci
vediamo è detto che si è scusato dove
stiamo
allora diciamo colavita ostacoli c'è
scritto e non abbiamo finito ancora
stata dub radio stato risultando
visibilità è sfracellato per la 150esima
volta
secondo me abbiamo quasi finito
[Applauso]
ecco la palestra guardate c'è l'insegna
con i pezzi giganti da evitare per marzo
salviamo e c'è scritto devi fare il
salto lungo altrimenti favalli rai
problemi a guardarci bene l'elicottero è
aggiunto è giunto il momento di fare
skydiving ma succede queste l'elicottero
se queste paracadute o donne sempre
cavour e quindi adesso possiamo buttarci
col paracadute
io l'ho detto prendere il paracadute a
questo ok
bello ei aspetta dove dobbiamo cadere
però cadere magari da dove dobbiamo
affermare che andare la altrimenti
cadiamo in diritti
a condire il paracadute turismo delle
navi per sfracellarsi però devi togliere
e mettere il paracadute
così c'è di più veloce che bello ma o no
questa è finita
i pezzi del sub ridevo il badge abbiamo
preso il peso
e abbiamo creato questa parte acquistata
su per le lunghe stata super divertente
e un super salta io sta cambiando
torniamo di nuovo sull'elicottero
consumi bello dove sei nata non lo sono
nel paradiso e che il bel 9 st super
divertente
io ti voglio dare un bel 10 perché la
parte finale mi è piaciuta troppo
davvero bellissimo a 10 per divertente
poi voto gli date scrivetelo nei
commenti e ora cliccate su una di queste
salite linea cliccate su quella che
preferite
buona visione ciao